مشهد لفت الانظار انظار رواد مواقع
التواصل لاب اردني كان مثلا اسمى لمعاني
الابوه والحنان حيث
ظهر مع ابنته في مشهد لن تنسى هذه الصغيره
طوال حياتها احمد عواد مشاهدينا الوالد
الحنون ظهر في مقطع فيديو وهو
لابنته ارياف خلال حفل مدرستها الفتاه لم
تجد زميلها الذي غابه عن الحفل وكان من
المفترض ان تكون رقصه معها ليتطوع الاب
ويحل محل الطفل جابرا بخاطر ابنته التي
فرحت بوجوده هلا بالحنون نال ارشادات
واسعه بتصرفه تجاه ابنته حيث وصل للمسرح
بسرعه ليكون بجانب ابنته مانعا عنها موقفا
مخرجا في طفولتها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا طلعت سيدي مدافع لابوه ويعني كان هدف
الوحيد اني اسعد بنتي
يعني كان يعني شفت انا مكسوره وشفت انا
يعني محتاجيتني وشفت المحتاجه سند فاني
حاولت اني
اني اسعد قد ما اقدر يعني
احمد طبعا انت يعني ادفات قلوبنا بهذا
الفيديو بس انا حابه احكي مع ارياف اذا في
مجال ارياف سمعتيني
حبيبتي كتير كان رقصتك حلوه
وحبيت اسالك انت شو حسيتي هيك لما شفتي
بابا فجاه بيركض وبيجي على المسرح عشان
يرقص معك لانه انت كنت واقفه لحالك
شو كان شعورك انبسطتي هيك لما شفتي بابا
عم بيركض احمد خليني اسالك بان اليوم
هذه هذا المقطع انتشر بشكل واسع على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ماذا تعنيها رياف لاحمد
خليني افهم هذه البنت اللي اللي وقفت شو
فكرت انت وانت صاعد وانت نازل من المسرح
طيب انت كنت رايح تجبر بخاطرها لما نزلت
من المسرح ايش فكرت فيه يعني استاذي ارياف
هي فرحه الاولى بالحياه
يعني الله يحفظها بس انا نسيت الناس نسيت
المسرح نسيت الجمهور فانك حاولت جاهدا قد
ما اقدر اني اسعدها يعني
حسيتك وكانك انت حافظ الرقصه من قبل بوقت
لانك طلعت مباشره واخذت الوضعيه الصح
علشان تكمل الرقصه معها لانها كانت يعني
زميلها مش مش موجود على ما يبدو كان غايب
يمكن عن العرض كنت تعرف كنت تعرف تفاصيل
هذه الرقصه او العرض اللي رح يقدموه
الاطفال للامانه لا ما كنت اعرف بس انا
حاولت اني اطلع على الاطفال اتفرج عليهم
بعمل زي حركاتهم يعني زي ما بيعملوا
الاطفال صرت بعمل زيهم يعني انا نزلت طفل
عشان اسعد بنتي